dans l'actualité également cette
entrevue entre anthony blinken et
sergueï lavrov une réunion russo
américaines à propos des tensions
grandissantes entre moscou et kiev dans
l'est de l'ukraine si les discussions
diplomatiques se poursuivent au loyer
sur le terrain l'arrivée massive de
troupes russes à la frontière
ukrainienne fait bien sûr craindre le
pire on retrouve gilbert craag notre
envoyé spécial dans le donbass bonjour
gulliver combat mouvements de troupes
quelles sont les dernières informations
dont vous disposez
alors selon le communiqué de l'armée
ukrainienne publié ce matin il y à une
nuit assez typique pour cette année dans
le donbass avec des combats à plusieurs
endroits de la ligne de front pas ici à
à venir quand même mais un petit cas il
y avait il y à deux jours des combats il
y avait des combats hier à cracovie fca
qui n'est pas loin d'ici les larmes et
fait état d'un soldat blessé mais qui
serait dans une condition stable
mercredi c'est la dernière fois qu'il y
a eu un soldat de l'armée ukrainienne
tuer la dernière fois que des positions
que pardon que dès que des domiciles que
des endroits civile ici à venir cas
avait été touché c'était au mois d'août
oliver comment réagissent les ukrainiens
après cette nouvelle escalade avec la
russie
alors ici active cas les gens disent que
ils ont l'impression que cette année il
y a plus de combats peut-être que
l'année dernière ça c'est pour la
plupart mais en fait les gens à qui on a
parlé sont pas exactement sur six est
pire cette année que l'année dernière
plus généralement sur la ligne de front
on a l'impression que depuis le
printemps de cette année les combats
s'intensifient et du coup bien sûr les
gens sont inquiets mais les gens dans le
donbass depuis sept ans maintenant ils
vivent dans cette tension permanente il
y à des combats il ya des périodes un
peu plus calmes il ya des périodes un
peu plus intense il y à des périodes où
il ya beaucoup de spéculations dans les
médias sur la possibilité d'une
éventuelle ré invasion si vous et par la
russie de cette région et les gens n'ont
pas envie d'y penser ils n'ont pas envie
vraiment de rentrer dans ces
spéculations ça c'est vraiment la
réponse qu'on reçoit de la plupart des
gens à qui on parle ici on n'a pas envie
d'y penser on n'a pas envie d'y croire
il aimerait que tout cela finisse et
qu'ils aient de nouveau accès à donetsk
où beaucoup de gens qui habitent ici ont
de la famille ou des amis et où ils
n'ont pas accès pour le moment mais ils
n'ont pas vraiment espoir que cela
advienne bientôt mais on n'a pas
l'impression non plus qu'ils vivraient
monde ont la peur que quelque chose de
pire arrive bientôt mais c'est peut-être
juste parce que ils n'ont plus vraiment
la force mentale de s'adresser à cette
question que arrivera arrivera c'est
c'est la réponse qu'on reçoit de la
plupart des personnes à qui on parle 1